[Music]
you're a big NBA fan I'm a big NBA fan I
actually believe it or not play in a
celebrity basketball league called the E
league and we had a playoff game
yesterday I played for this team Boston
so I have a full uniform and the
referees and stuff goes on yeah it has
no affiliation to the city and so so
anyway I'm playing and it's a very
intense game you know what I mean really
cuz I would think celebrity games maybe
aren't as intense
have you seen actors in real life like
imagine them all together on a
basketball court wearing uniforms like
it's just they get crazy oh it's so
cheap and people are yelling each other
yo man you cold you can't shoot a
three-pointer and all that stuff and I
just get really like like nervous and I
just start yelling in insane stuff to
confuse them because my street talk
isn't very good as you can imagine yeah
yeah yeah yeah I'll just saw everyone's
like a man you cold and I'm like I like
lamps and get the game I have to feed my
six children yeah and then the guy who's
like talking [ __ ] he's just like wait
what I think do you like to drink 1%
milk
that's really it confuses them and then
then I defeat them when I cross over
because they have no idea what I'm
saying who's the toughest like are there
any celebrities who are surprisingly
good like there's a there was a ex-nfl
player called terrell I heard you pulled
teeth oh yeah tear alone never have this
guy he see you play against him so this
is funny he's a he's six six okay size X
and I'm playing against his team and in
one in he gets a fast break and I run
back and I all I see is this guy coming
towards me and I'm like he's going to
dunk on me like this is the last day of
my life
so so I jump up and I just grab his arm
and I can I get the foul okay done then
next possession he's coming towards me
again again on a fast break and I'm
thinking oh I'm gonna outsmart him as
soon as he comes I'm just gonna standing
this and take the charge and my whole
bench is gonna go crazy
yeah man you got him you got him you got
him so this is how its unfolding in my
head and he's coming and I'm like here
it is and I stand and I closed my eyes
like this and he takes one step here one
step here and he dunks behind me so the
whole time I'm like yeah and I do this
and he's just gone and my old team is
like what's wrong with you why did you
foul him why are you trying to take a
charge are you stupid
I thought that you just stood there with
your eyes closed hugging yourself
exactly like maybe this isn't happening
I look at the size of that that's the
key he says look at that man yeah watch
your own fault for just trying to save
him yeah I thinks you try your eye like
lamps move yeah that's I should onions
are nutritious yeah just shout that I'm
a real boy or something
oh I thought about this I've gotten to
know you a little bit because Big Bang
Theory tapes just across the way yes and
and and I've gotten to know you guys a
little bit you famously play a nerd do
you feel like you do nerdy things in
real life yeah I'm a huge fan of Star
Wars I'm a huge fan above a lot of the
rings' like I can quote some of those
nine some of the movies so but I'm going
to quote lines from the Lord of the
Rings yeah yeah yeah yeah what are your
favorite parts of Lord of the room well
I'll tell you one thing that like all
the women love Legolas in the movie
right played by the handsome Orlando
Bloom but if you actually watch the
movie Orlando that all Legolas does is
basically point out the obvious in every
scene so there's a scene where literally
he's doing a ten there's a 10-minute
conversation about the war that has just
taken place and Orlando Bloom literally
he's like he looks like literally into
the camera he's like a diversion and
you're like thank you captain obvious
yeah but you still love them you love
those I love those movies I mean I cried
when the third one came out even in the
beginning of the theme music I started
crying I do think what I don't know if
you've how you feel about this but well
I want to watch I love Laura the Ring
movie when I do watch them I sometimes
think they could start saying anything
and I would go along with it because I
lose track yeah you know it's a little
like Game of Thrones you could just
start saying things like we must go to
band a bar where the jub jubs lie then
the corncobs will be in Santa Bor and I
you know I don't know I'm just curious
so they ever just throw in nonsense I
mean infuse us listen there are people
who take that very seriously and you've
offended all of them job job is the name
of my hometown
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]